hello freak bitches just because we're
trying to sell you the best shit
possible at the lowest price possible
that is the number one goal with on it
and everything we sell you is shit we
use just ourselves kettlebells no
scarves yeah mom against old dudes with
scarves like a big Randy Couture fee on
its scar he's been wearing a scarf
lately and I just want to talk to him
does he really yeah Randy Couture's was
such a bad motherfucker to turn around
as my wife who cares
like I'm ballet being a leotard and I'd
still be like stay away from yeah he
could go out to clubs with a legitimate
albatross around his neck you wouldn't
care so he in which did you see Matt
McConaughey in Magic Mike no I missed
that I never met anybody wanted to have
sex with themselves more that guy really
can Oh God
I mean he I guarantee jerks officers
highlight-reel he basically has just
stock footage of him stretching and
nutation his character or Matt McConnell
talking about Matt McConaughey the human
how do you want ladies an actor's like
magic it's like why don't you take that
role one day and take that role
you took that role so you can wear
outfits and go and go that's what
doesn't I've never saw okay well now I
have to go I'll do it it's a bigger wish
we were talking about the commercials
whoo sorry sorry sorry sorry
cuz I need to know about this cuz I saw
the ad for that I got a little panicky
oh no yeah day that I was like what's
going on here what is this hey Tatum
O'Neal or whatever the guys name tater
that he's also handsome fellow he
couldn't look better
Oh handsomest guy I hung out with him in
Vegas for a weekend women literally
start just ovulating in his presence and
he's a great guy they must panic there's
certain types of comedy where you know
you and I were talking also about how
what a privilege it is to feel it to be
a headliner and to be someone who gets
to perform all the country yeah it's
amazing look sometimes I look at I was
in Miami like Fort Lauderdale and I just
you know it was I did you know I got I'm
at one point I just had him going you
know pretty strong and I just looked at
I was like I felt like the luckiest
human being in the fucking world that's
why when I watch Matt McConaughey in
fucking Magic Mike in his fucking
leather chest girdle and his fucking hot
pants and any and he's coming off
yeah did it hey hey yo ker boy come fuck
and do ten minutes of stand-up you
fucking idiot I don't jump off stage
like I just did an hour and a half
across somebody hug me hard so I guess
you're Wells this animosity of course
I'm just I'm attracted to him all right
Express I mean I hate him I mean I hate
him I mean I don't know set you in
Malibu no I was just thinking about how
you know you're you're an actor and you
you have five scenes in a movie and feel
like whoa you were great in that movie
it you're collectively are probably
doing 10 or 15 minutes of actual
activity whereas when you do stand-up
you're out there for you know it's just
a different it's just a different thing
feels it feels well why would you care
though that he wants something
who doesn't hate him so much it doesn't
matter what's going on no I just saw the
movie and I was just I was just looking
I'm going to you're just you took this
movie just so you could wear those
outfits he gave me a biggest boner
didn't he he did if I was if I was gay I
would definitely he's a very attractive
man would you choose every shit Mike Oh
Channing Tatum really it's my boy
you can't he's got he's got best
genetics he's got thick lips I got nice
skin the eyes on the cat eyes seems
confident too he's a great guy he's got
a big car sense of humor Jesus were both
really something Joe Rogan's a broad
gallon gas it gets talked about Channing
Tatum's cos oh did you want you just a
baby that just came out of you just went
I bet he's got a big best gun a big cock
did you uh did you watch the app the
actual whole movie yeah because I wanted
to annoy myself more and more although I
thought the movie was good and I love
you a little eggs I like Channing Tatum
I mean I had my hands that movie looks
so gay and I'm flipping through the
channels I was slipping through the
channels and I saw it it popped up and I
went whoa change it quick but like you
know how you're flipping through like
you're previewing the next preview now I
get am at a hotel was chilling in a
hotel and there's like I was like this
is okay gotta get it up like dudes were
like gyrating back and forth which by
the way I don't think women like that I
think that motion is really just
isolated someone riding dicks I don't
think that I know gyrating like the way
a guys doing women like thrusting they
like to get fuck they don't they want
you you're going you dick riding circle
man
dick riding sweaty circle moon
McConaughey's doing he's got a fucking a
leather thong and he's doing back bends
and shipping and but the character I was
watching I was it what bothered me was I
was watching I go you know as an actor
if I took that role there's a lot I'd do
that role maybe but I wouldn't because
there's not a lot to do like he played
it just one shut the fuck up bitch she
would take that role at a goddamn heart
I got you and Channing Tatum in your
underwear yeah that guy would be your
boyfriend you'd be carried around like
he was crossing the the wedding no I
would look like I have fucking rickets
next to that guy's yeah I want to be
would do the movie with him no dude you
would do it so shut the fuck up he's
given it Matthew McConaughey a hard time
and you're doing the movie maybe he just
wanted to meet Channing Tatum - you know
what man Matthew I'm sorry brother I
don't mean to put you down
you got enough guy yeah I hear but I
hear he's a very nice guy
yeah here's a nice car doesn't mean he's
not really vain and not an annoying
Mellisa man he's playing a part how
could you like if you judge me based on
the movie zookeeper you douche bag of
fucking convinced in Malibu he does yeah
with a shirt off no he doesn't yeh does
if I see you and you're doing push-ups
in front of Pavilion in Malibu I'm gonna
take your back that's right I'm gonna
take you back and I'm gonna get the
hooks in my throat just kick him in the
ribs me I'm just gonna hold he can
scream all you want you shouldn't have
been doing push-ups
he's not allowed to do that off with a
knapsack on with a knapsack on a bandana
while tourists take pictures of you is
that what who's doing yeah that annoys
me he wanted to be really fit for this
movie maybe it was like something he was
working on like what kind of
exhibitionist could he become because he
was playing a part in a movie man did
you murder he kabocha look think about
look what would what's-his-name does
when he does um Daniel day-lewis when he
gets an immersed in a role
he's like mean he's unbelievably
immersive maybe that's what Matthew
McConaughey was just being a douche bag
don't agree he's playing a douchebag in
the movie and that's douche bag activity
the role wasn't so much of a douche bag
the role is more of I just think he's
supposed to be the club owner but you'll
see what I mean would it be okay if he
did push-ups in a we're in place where
nobody could say like say if there was
like his there was like some grass in
front of his car and nobody could say
any drop down for a quick fifth no
here's the bomb okay what that's what
bothers me yes there I am but here's
what bothers me if you work out just for
the sake of vanity and then and then and
then it would I when I see what you're
doing is just you're just sculpting
or for it to be a peacock I understand I
get I get staying in shape there's
something about it if it's not for
something functional it was not for
something like that you're doing
I immediately I'm just saying you can do
it you're not my friend that's all I
said yeah my friend why is that what
about a guy who's just doing like bench
presses and curls never touches the legs
just want to look good in a tight shirt
but he's doing it you know what you know
you know why I like that why I got no
problem with that he's doing it so he
can go out and get laid on a Saturday
night
fucking-a god bless you what do you
think Matthew McConaughey is doing when
he's wearing leather underwear doing us
so he can fucking get the the dailies
and jerk off to himself okay that's why
he's fucking doing it and there's a
difference when I see Matt McConaughey
doing a roll like that Magic Mike all
I'm seeing something masturbatory I
watched Channing Tatum he's trying to do
something he's actually playing a
character who's fucking conflicted about
being a 30 year old stripper and it's
fucking great McConaughey is is it's a
masturbatory performance he's watching
himself he's not trying to do anything
he's not trying to express any well
that's not that's he's what it's not
trying to play I mean the guy is shown a
pretty broad range of great in the world
television no Miriam I don't want to
marry him but he was really good in
contact the hell's going on he was
alright he was good in contact I enjoyed
him I thought he was sensitive on me
without town seemed like the type of guy
that would fall in love with Jodie
Foster that was a long time ago um who
the fuck would why did you watch that I
don't know what happened to you I was
dropped on your head by renting this you
see lives count 100 mrs. Callen wanted
to watch all right he's teeth blame you
Wow I might have to get Thai and watch
it but I'll probably get really scared
I'll probably have to get my god Mike
you get a little jealous you better be
inside of a pussy when you watch it
really time I don't have that kind of
stamina or desire or cosmetic or will
that's why you need to fuck I got
tricked early on in life but I figured
it out now I'm fine just beating off and
then going about my business
you